all right Cherry yes Cherry yo where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
uh born and raised in Dallas Texas
Dallas and tell me about your family oh
my family
um
my parents divorced when I was really
young so my dad I don't know I haven't
seen him since I was 18 17 18. uh me and
my mom are really close my mom is like
my best friend I tell her everything
same with my Grandma we're really close
um
closer to my mom's side of the family uh
not really much of my dad's like that
but oh you describe your childhood my
childhood
pretty uh
I would say I was more um on the broke
side in my childhood
um growing up we didn't have a lot of
money I was always told like we don't
have any money growing up but um I had a
fun childhood though I'll say I spent
most of my childhood outside
surrounded by the pool and my dog and
it's pretty uneventful but it sounds
nice it was fun no nothing no no nothing
necessarily traumatic like that
um
I will say my parents got divorced when
I was really young though because my dad
was it's always rough it's always rough
but my dad was definitely a cheating
piece of [ __ ] so lovely narcissistic
I feel like you know Daddy Issues nice
and
what kind of kid were you in high school
oh I was bad I was a badass little kid
um oh my God my mom
I was a bad little kid I went to four
high schools I lived with my
mom I 16 she kicked me out because
um I was my mom was married to my
stepdad most of my life so he was mainly
like my father figure when I was 15
um 14 or 15 they got a divorce so I
ended up moving from my high school to
another high school I went from
Princeton High School to Hebron High
School which is over in Dallas Texas
and um
I remember at 16 like my mom was like
dating around and stuff and I was just
skipping school all the time I used to
skip and during lunch time we had like a
a double block so it was like an hour
long there was only two lunch periods
that were an hour each
um and I remember I the other half of
the hour I would go with my homegirl to
the back of the bleachers in the
football stadium and we would get
absolutely high off our asses just
completely high and I would come back
after a block lunch and I would be in my
math class just completely like
obliterated like
horrible
um but yeah I used to skip school all
the time and whenever my mama catch me
I'd be like oh Mr bias and then she come
home and she's like I'm gonna beat your
[ __ ] ass she's like you need to take
your ass to school and I was just like
No And so my mom kicked me out when I
was 16 and I lived with my dad for the
first time ever in my entire life
which was
half cool half horrible because my dad's
[ __ ] psycho and I remember
um he was just very like you're not
gonna tell me what you're doing or what
you're not gonna do but he was also like
I don't care if you go drink or do
whatever the [ __ ] just tell me what
you're doing so he was very strict but
at the same time he was very like
non-strict so it was really confusing
because he would always like tell me not
to do something but then he'd allowed me
to do the same thing you know so it was
very like confusing
um and then I went from living with my
dad to living with my grandma and then I
was bad at my grandma's too uh I was a
horrible little kid because she went to
the hospital for three days and I threw
a party for three days straight
yeah
I was like paying people I was having
people pay entry to get in like
it's really bad I had three of The
Neighbors when she came out the hospital
snitch on me when did Sex work start for
you oh sex work as soon as I turned 18.
as soon as I turned 18
um I actually met a girl on Instagram
little did I know uh that she was trying
to pimp on me because she had a pimp and
I didn't know that I was really young
and so I was naive
um and so I hung out with her in this
dude and then she was like oh but like
at the end of the night you need to give
us the money I'm like why would I give
you the money and I started dancing with
her right it was my first time ever
shipping
um she was like yeah you got to give us
the money at the end of the night I'm
like why would I do that and so I was
like no [ __ ] you and I immediately left
I was like No And then I started dancing
with my homegirl Taylor which
um she was like oh I work at this one
called bucks wild in Dallas and so I
started working there as a first strip
club
um ever really worked out was baby dolls
and Bucks wild and it was pretty good I
liked it I was making great money it was
um different though because I wasn't
used to
making money like that so it was like
fast paced I was getting drunk every
night and I was in the strip club just
Wilder it was fun
and you're still doing it today I'm
still yeah I'm still a stripper I've
been dancing for five years now how old
are you 23 23 23 yeah
what does Mom think of you being a
stripper
my mom
um like I said like my mom is my best
friend I tell her everything she she
knows about me stripping and she doesn't
care as long as I'm not doing like the
extras but even then being in the strip
club most of the time realistically a
lot of girls do do I shows in the club
but let it goes what a lot of girls do
do extras in the club oh yeah yeah but
yeah admit it so oh they don't want to
admit it but I've seen these girls
behind closed doors and you know I'm not
gonna blast their name on the internet
but these girls they do do [ __ ] behind
closed doors they act like they don't
but they do
that's how most of the time they're
walking out with thousands of dollars at
the club
that or they get the guy unbelievably
like coked out or [ __ ] up and
don't ask them out of his money and
that's the reality behind it a lot of
girls don't like to talk about that but
it that's how it happens if you learned
things about men from doing this for
five years
[Applause]
but I think it's [ __ ] up my
perspective on men given the dad you had
maybe you didn't change your views on
them
actually I think he's pretty much like
the man in the strip club
like he I remember
um when I was younger I didn't really
like reciprocate kind of like what he
was putting down but he would always
tell me like your daddy is a player like
um and he's married to his wife I don't
even know if they're still together I
don't talk to him but he's like your
daddy's a player
um I'm talking to this one girl at my
job and when I was like 15 or 16 he was
asking me to hold photos of this girl
while he was married and sent them to me
to my phone so I could hold on to the
photos so his wife wouldn't find them
so that already [ __ ] up my perspective
on men it was like damn so it's like all
guys are kind of like this
because I grew up with a dad that was
like that
and then um going into the strip club
and seeing how men were
I guess that doesn't necessarily change
my perspective on them but I think it
kind of
is like a
what is it like just a certain group of
men that you're around all the time and
you're like okay it kind of makes you
feel like a lot of men can be like that
does that make sense yeah have you had
relationships personal I've only ever
had one relationship and he was just
like my dad
you know I've never been like oh like oh
you attract like
what your parents are like but I've only
been in one relationship and my mom was
like he is just like your dad and I was
like damn
he was very narcissistic and abusive and
just a liar and a cheater and very
sneaky
I've only ever had one relationship
though I've had situationships
uh but only one actual relationship
in our drugs something you use just to
get up on stage and do your job
um no I don't use drugs but I will say
um liquid courage definitely drink
um
I had like a time span
where I didn't drink like that but I
wasn't making as much money and so it's
like when I'm drunk It's like butter
like I can speak smoother and I'm able
to make sales and it's easier for me to
talk to people and like fake it because
when I'm sober I think men can kind of
like sense the the anxiety of me
like talking to them and trying to make
sales it's kind of like a weird tension
and when I'm drunk It's easy it's just
like better I'm able to like Smooth talk
them and get to get them to either buy
dances or get a VIP room
how does this work affect you
emotionally
oh it's horrible
uh body dysmorphia and the strip club is
real I don't know what I look like half
the time
um I'll have days where I feel really
pretty and really skinny and then I have
other days where I feel fat and I feel
really ugly and I don't know what I look
like and then you have the men that come
to the club and they're just really
disrespectful and they make like weird
comments on your body like calling you
fat or something like that
um so it's like half the time I don't
know what I actually look like
body dysmorphia on the strip clubs it's
real and it's hard not every woman can
do this right
yeah very thick skin I would think yeah
I think it's definitely
um really hard for your mental I think
it's glamorized because of social media
nowadays but it's it's really hard for
your mental being over sexualized like
that at um all times especially when
it's your job as a sex worker
it can be really hard it's definitely
stressful in a mental is there anything
you had
dreams of doing when you were younger
or even now you're still young
I always dreamed of cosplaying like
full-time like as like anime and gaming
um I've been watching anime since second
grade like basically since I was born
um so just like gaming cosplaying and
being kind of like a social media
influencer but it's just so mainstream
now I feel like it'd be kind of
difficult
you make good money doing this
stripping yeah yeah I can make good
money I've had nights
um where I've made nothing but I've had
nights where I've almost made ten
thousand dollars so it really just
depends on where you go and where you
work but I feel like there's always slow
season so you got to move around when it
comes you go to different cities to do
this yeah so
um I'll go to La I'll go to Houston I'll
go to Dallas wherever the money is at
because
um sometimes it could be slower and then
like if it's slower you might want to go
to Miami because Miami is a travel City
everybody's partying in Miami all the
time go to out to Miami you can make a
thousand two thousand minimum a night
that could be pretty average in Miami
but if you go to Texas sometimes you'd
be lucky to make two to three hundred
during slow season which slow season is
usually like around like Christmas time
to like October November December
do you think you get addicted to the
fast money oh absolutely it's very
addicting because I've tried getting out
of the sex scene or um the sex work
scene before and working like nine to
fives and normal jobs like I went to a
bartending school I've tried investing
in myself and doing other things with
myself to try to get out of the
lifestyle
my anxiety don't allow it I know how to
make sales in the strip club and on top
of it I feel like I'm just able to make
so much money so fast like lap dances
and VIP rooms and stuff like that that
when I went and worked the nine to five
job and I work nine ten hour shifts and
make 120 I'm like [ __ ] that
that is not worth it and I take my ass
right back to the strip club like two to
three days later the website is to make
great money yeah what are the downsides
of this lifestyle the downsides of the
live
lives definitely I would say health-wise
because
when you're drinking every day it can be
really bad for your health because
you're literally drinking waking up
slightly hungover then you're sleeping
through the whole day and then you're
literally waking up feeling like [ __ ]
and then getting ready and then going to
work and then doing it again and it's
kind of just a repetition of
work sleep hungover getting ready
work drunk sleep
repeat there's a wear and tear of it's
basically a dark lifestyle you know
you're not working in a flower shop
you're working in a strip club oh yeah
absolutely does that get to you after a
while
well working in the strip club
in in sex work industry where you're
dealing with guys that are mostly
probably drunk and probably cheating on
their wives or girlfriends
and it's just not
typically what you would dream about
doing if you're a young girl oh
absolutely not when I was younger even
17 like 17
um
I was very like I wouldn't even change
in front of people and now I have only
fans I do like
um shipping and only fans now I'm just
like I don't even I don't care anymore
it doesn't even phase me I think I've
been around new girls and nude people
and been in the sex work so long now for
five years that
um people will change around me nude and
it doesn't even phase me I'm so like
numb to it because I've been around so
long and it's crazy because if younger
me saw me now she would be like
what are you doing she'd be like oh my
God nudity you know what I'm saying so
it's like now I'm just so it doesn't
even phase me anymore how is it how is
this working in this industry for five
years changing it this year
self-worth been impacted
uh I think so because I feel like
you can build up your confidence I would
think
ah yes and no that's that's kind of hard
that's a hard kind of question
um
about relationships and love I think
it's hard because a lot of men they're
like I don't want a sex worker as a
girlfriend but at the same time those
are the same men that support sex
workers the most they're the ones that
are paying for the only fans they're the
ones that are following these girls on
Instagram and interactions and giving
them the likes and it's just like I've
always been so over sexualized that I
was kind of like [ __ ] it and if you're
gonna over sexualize me anyways I'm
gonna get paid off of it and that's kind
of like the mental I've had ever since
then
and they hate it guys hate it so much
like they over sexualize us so much and
then when I decide to use that to my
advantage and profit off of it they hate
it it's like will you over sexualize me
anyway so when I build off of that and
make money off of it why is it an issue
now
it's just not fair it's everyday sex
workers describe men as very easy
they're so simple and easy to
play from what I've experienced yeah
I want to say all men but a lot
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
oh God I probably wouldn't even be in
sex work if I was like like younger you
know what I'm saying I was kind of like
manipulated and didn't really know what
I was getting myself into
I kind of wish I would have went a route
of getting a normal job so I wouldn't be
addicted to the fast money but at the
same time I can't like repeat live so it
is what it is
it's already out there might as well
make money on it now is it a lonely
lifestyle
it can be lonely sometimes but I don't
think my priority is even a relationship
to begin with do you have friends
do I have friends yeah I have a lot of
friends you're surprised how many women
will tell me they don't have friends
really in the sex work industry yeah
I will say
um
it could be kind of like competitive I
feel like there's a lot of girls out
there that'll be secretly in competition
with you but I feel like my friends for
the most part
are either
sex workers themselves or
I don't know
they're not judgmental the ones that I
do have they don't really care about
what I do they're very supportive
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking about considering
doing something like this the internet
is forever don't make rash decisions
make sure before you rush into something
that's glamorized that you do your
research on it I understand that like I
said the internet is forever and that if
you're posting your body online it's
never going to go away
it'll always be out there and there is a
lot of people that you'll be exposing
yourself to on the internet that can
potentially harm you or stalk you or
watch you or observe you or any of the
above so you want to be safe and you
want to be careful so just make sure
that you really do your research on this
lifestyle and don't just rush into it
it's not easy and it's really hard on
your mental and your body
have you had stalkers or bad things
happen to you
um
nothing too crazy I've had people
recognize me and I've had men because
I'm in sex work recognizing on the
street they'll try to ground my titty
around my ass just because I'm a sex
worker I'm like don't [ __ ] touch me
and so like when I get aggressive with
them they don't expect it they expect me
to be like this online Persona of this
girl and then I'm like don't [ __ ]
touch me and I get aggressive with them
they're like well I didn't expect you to
be like that like well just because I'm
a sex worker doesn't give you permission
to touch me without like asking it's
still consent you have to ask for
consent I would say that's probably like
the only issue I've had where like fans
will get like handsy and I'm like I
don't know you don't touch me
what do you think people are not
sex workers that are just squares don't
understand about girls that do this what
do I think about that what do you think
they don't understand about girls that
do this
ah I'm I'm not sure
um
because so many people think that you
guys are just a bunch of sex craved
women oh not even I honestly would
consider myself more towards asexual
even though I'm a sex worker and what
people they're like like when I tell
guys that they're like what well you
have only fans you have you're a
stripper like what do you mean you're
asexual and I'm like do you really think
I'm like horny 24 8 just because I'm a
sex worker that's like a weird like
assumption guys make like I think
because I'm a sex worker too it makes me
not care about sex like that because I'm
so over sexualized all the time that
it's like you crave a genuine connection
and it's really hard to find because I
am a sex worker and my body's out there
and it's everywhere and so I'm over
sexualized all the time that like
it's hard to find something like that
Cherry what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
in life oh that's a really good question
um
stop rushing into things I rush into
things I am so uh what is it called like
sporadic
I made the worst [ __ ] decisions ever
can you see me oh yes spontaneous I'm so
spontaneous don't don't do what I do do
not do what I do I I jump into things
like think before you do things don't
jump into things that's like the best
advice I could give anybody like
chill make sure you think things through
before you do them that's probably the
best advice I can give all right candy
thank you so much for sharing your story
yeah absolutely be careful out there
make a lot of money
always thank you very much